Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Decent. I'm your host as always, Ricardo Loops. And
today I'm joined by Doctor Jean Manuel Rubin. He
is a professor of Ancient History at University. He
is a classic, a scholar who specializes in Greek
antiquity, the historical anthropology of sport and the history
of social inequalities. And today we're focusing on his
book, The Dangerous Life and Ideas Of Diogenes, The
Cynic. So Jean Manuel, welcome to the show. It's
a pleasure to everyone. Thank
you. Thank you. It's a
pleasure to be there. So, just before we get
into diogenes self, just to get a little bit
of historical background, historical context to the period where
he lived. So uh back then, uh te tell
us about this idea about how, how apparently back
then uh many ancient Greek philosophers thought of philosophy
as a way of life. And why perhaps this
is relevant for discussing uh diogenes philosophy.
Yes. Uh You have different uh uh form of
uh Greek and Roman philosophies who are conceived as
a uh ethic philosophy, meaning philosophy of life, uh
philosophy, which is providing a kind of uh uh
moral compass, moral scheme uh to uh organize your
choices and to decide what is wrong and what
is right in life. And the, the, the maybe
the beginning of this movement is uh with Socrates.
And the Diogenes is a pupil of Antisthenes, which
is who is a pupil of Socrates. So you
have this kind of Greek tradition of uh um
building um schools of thought uh which are a
way of life, ways of life at the same
time. And cynicism is strongly based on these ideas,
ideas that you cannot be only uh a philosopher
producing ideas, but you have to uh leave them
in your everyday life. So you cannot be only
a scholar. You have to be a kind of
agent of your philosophy.
And what was basically the context of the wider
Mediterranean world back in the fourth century BC, which
is apparently when Diogenes lived.
Yeah, he's born at the end of the fifth
century BC and he died during the 300 twenties
uh around that. Um So, yeah, he's a man
of the fourth century BC. Uh It's a, it's
an opening world, meaning that there is a kind
of very dynamic international economy at the time and
lots of conflicts too around the Aegean Sea. And
the thing is we have what is interesting is
there are lots of foreigners moving from one city
to the other and diogenes was one of them
because he suffered from an exile. He had to
exile from his city, Sy up on the Black
Greek City and is one of these many thousands
of foreigners going from one city to another. And
the fourth century BC is really a moment when
we see lots of foreigners in different cities, we
cannot really observe that before. There were some foreigners
at the fifth or the sixth century BC in
the cities, cities were not closed communities but maybe
not so many. Mhm So maybe that's, that's the
first thing. The second thing is you have at
the same time in the fourth century, you have
very little cities, meaning with 3000 inhabitants. And you
have also very large ones like Syracuse like Alexandria
at the end of the first century, like Rhodes,
like Athens and Corinth and Athens and Corinth were
two of the largest cities of the time. And
Diogenes choose to live alternately in each of them.
He was living during the, during the the winter
in Athens and during the summer in in, in
Corinth. So he was living in very large city
which are very specific kind of city, city with
a lot of different nationalities, people from all over
the Mediterranean world.
So tell us a little bit about perhaps what
were some of the main events in the life
of diogenes that you think really played the biggest
role in shaping his philosophy? Because I mean, I
know that he was exiled at a certain point
and then he leave the situation there in different
cities. So tell us a little bit about why,
why that happened and why he basically had to
be moving between different cities because I guess that
then later on plays a role in aspects of
his way of thinking and philosophy.
Um YEAH, he is, he is in exile. So
he, he has to flee from his city for
a very specific reason. He was involved with his
father uh in a kind of uh money counterfeiting
affair case. And uh he had to go away
to avoid prison or even execution. So he left
his city. We don't know exactly when, but it
could be in the 300 sixties around that, that
he had to leave the city. And I think
his exile in the fourth century BC doesn't mean
the same maybe or maybe it means the same
as today. It's a very hard uh experiment of
life. It's considered by ancient people as the kind
of ultimate uh detachment, uh ultimate loss. Uh Because
when I was talking about lots of foreigners in
the 400 century world, most of them were coming
back on a regular basis to their city, their
original cities, they were just moving from one to
the other doing some uh trade, but they were
back to the city. And then you have exiles
and exile is a very complicated thing because then
it means you lose your complete social environment, you
lose the ability to get buried when you die
in your, the earth, the ground of your motherland,
which means a lot to an ancient Greek of
the, of the time. So this, this is the
first really traumatic experience of diogenes uh life. And
um this is the beginning, in fact of his
philosophical career, we don't know if uh two months,
six months, two years, five years uh happened before
or between the exile and the beginning of the
philosophical life. But we know that there is a
kind of very strong link between the two episodes.
Uh The thing is when you lose attached to
your, to your city, uh you lose your, your
main belonging, you were suppose in a Greek world,
you are supposed to belong to your family, to
your neighborhood, to your village, to your city mainly.
And then you, you are apart from this uh
belonging and this kind of experience of detachment uh
had a strong effect on uh um the way
uh diogenes conceived his philosophy because cynicism is a
philosophy of detachment. You are, you are supposed to
refuse uh every kind of belonging. You're not supposed
to get married, you're not supposed to build a
family. Uh Family is a cultural construct. City is
a cultural construct. So uh there is a, there
is a clear link between the experience of exile
and the, the way diogenes shaped uh cynicism philosophy,
cynic philosophy.
So this is one of the main ways we
got into the idea of cosmopolitan, cosmopolitanism, right. Yeah,
this is one of the routes. Uh There is
maybe a second uh context uh element which is
Sinop is the original city. Is a native uh
city, is a city on the south shore of
the Black Sea, uh meaning uh north of Asia
Minor. Uh And here at the time, there are
lots of um barbarian uh ethnic. Many of them
were in the Persian Empire and were, which are
in contact with uh Syn O or threatening Syn
up on the other Greek cities of the Black
Sea, meaning that very early diogenes had a personal
experience of the relationship with other culture, other ethnic
non-greek uh people. Uh So, so the, the cosmopolitanism,
which is uh which is credited of the invention
um the cosmopolitanism uh is at the same time,
can be understood as a, as a consequence of
his exile. And at the same time, uh of
his experience of uh barbarian uh ethnic and conflicts
in Asia Minor.
Yes. And by the way back then, because uh
in the kind of world we live in nowadays,
things work, I guess very differently. But back then
moving, for example, between cities and between states, I
mean, how hard or easy was it? Because I
mean, I imagine that back then people didn't have
really documentation and but then when it came to,
for example, the social and political status of an
exile or someone was not considered a citizen. I
mean, how did it work back then? I would
imagine it would vary between, for example, city states
in Greece, how would they deal with those kinds
of people? But how was it back then? A
living that way?
Yes. Yes, there are different situations. Every city is
a kind of, is a city state. So it's
a kind of very little nation if you want.
So, so, so you have a body of citizens.
They are the one with the power, the political
power, uh and the the uh judiciary power. So
they, they go, they, they are working in courts,
they are working in the assembly, in the councils,
et cetera, then you are foreigners. So if you
are in exile, uh the normal situation, if you
are free, if you're not a slave, the normal
situation is, is is that you will be a
resident for now. Uh THEN in some very specific
situations, some cities including Athens um build some uh
like exclusive personal status from uh for exiles coming
from a city that is a kind of ally
city. So when you have a civil war in
an allied city and when the democratic people are
exiled from their city, it has happened in the
fifth and the fourth century, we see that Athens
built some very um um exclusive with some privileged
uh personal status for this group of exiles. But
this didn't happen to diogenes when he arrived in
Athens or in Corinth, he was only just a
kind of resident foreigner. So you have to register,
uh and you have to pay taxes as a
resident foreigner, which is very important. It's not very
expensive, but it's very important because if you don't,
you are suspected to try to pretend you're a
citizen. If you don't pay the foreigner tax, then
you are, you can suffer a trial and there
are some heavy risk uh with that coming. So
uh the the situation where you are moving from
one city to the other is is that you
will be uh if you are there for some
days or some weeks, you will be like a
provisory foreigner and then there is no administration, but
you have no rights either. Meaning that if you
are threatened, beaten, stolen, you have no way to
defend yourself in court. Uh But then when you
are a resident for Rena, then you have a
kind of protection from the city, but you have
no political right, no judiciary, right? Meaning you, you
cannot, uh you cannot vote in a court, you
cannot vote in an assembly, you cannot be a
magistrate. So that's the situation for free people. Of
course, for, if you are suspected to be a
slave, then the situation is even different.
And by the way, diogenes himself was a slave
for a little while.
Yes. Uh DURING the 300 forties, it's been abducted
by pirates, which was a very not, not common
that uh not unusual event. There are lots of
pirates in the Aegean and Mediterranean Sea at the
time. And even Alexander, the Great had to uh
to fight against pirates around crete for some time.
Uh And uh yes, so the pirates were attacking
villages, they were abducting people and then uh two
ways. The first way is they were asking for
a ransom and they were giving back the people
they had abducted if they got the ransom. First
situation, second situation, they were um going away from
the place where they did the abduction and selling
everyone on a market slave. That's what happened to
diogenes. It's been uh it's been sold to a
Corinthian uh Man Xenia. And after some years he's
been released, freed and franchised. So, yes, he, he
had an exper a personal experience of uh uh
slavery. He's not the only philosopher who had that
experience, but he's one, he's one of them and
lots of people had this experience and this fear
to be abducted by pirates. Yes.
Mhm And I mean, of course, I imagine that
he was exposed to different cultures. So was the
uh cultural relativist in any way.
Yes. Uh Yeah, in a way you could, you
could say that he, he, he, he had the
idea that lots of uh things in everyday social
life were culturally, culturally built. So uh he was
uh looking as most of social conventions as convention
on social customs as customs, meaning for diogenes, marriage
was a cultural uh custom, family was a cultural
uh custom wealth as a cultural custom. So in
a way, uh when you develop this kind of
uh um philosophy, you could, you could say you
are a cultural relativist meaning that you are. But
the thing is he was, he was not interested
in comparing culture was interesting and uh in opposing
culture and nature.
Yeah. And basically, I guess that through his life
experiences, it became easier for him to basically question
norms.
He spent most of his life doing that. Absolutely.
Doing, trying to uh to unbuilt uh uh norms
and to, to not, not always to contest them
but to question them to, to make people understand
that they were only customs norms and they were
not facts uh by nature. So it was a,
it is a big part of uh uh cynicism
uh that the to, to, to point at uh
culturally built uh ways of life.
Yes. Mhm A and the uh in the book,
you also talk about how one of his ideas
was about attacking uh power, glory and the obs
the obsession some people have with social status. Could
you tell us about that
uh attack, you said glory and of social status
and obsession with social status.
In fact, for diogenes, there are important matters, philosophical
ones and they are superficial matters and to Search
for power is a kind of super, super act
to search for glory. If you are an athlete
or political um um leader or a military leader
is a, is a superficial one. And to search
for better status too, meaning that uh for dere,
if you are a slave, you don't need to
search for freedom. If you are a foreigner, you
don't need to search for citizenship. If you are
a citizen, you don't need to search for uh
kind of better political position in your city. All
of these are superficial goals. They are not helping
you uh in a philosophical way to behave uh
better uh without um pursuing uh artificial goals. So
uh one of the parts of cynicism was to
point at those um artificial uh artificial goals and
intentions. You are supposed to go back to what
is essential, what is necessary needs uh not nothing
uh extravagant and the power is considered as a
kind of uh useless uh goal and glory to
a athletes are attacked on a regular basis because
they are uh two diogenes, eyes focused uh on
uh the search of glory instead of being focused
on the search of philosophy.
And of course, he ended up living in poverty
most of his life. And in the book, he
talked about how he distinguished between the fact of
poverty and the feeling of poverty. So, what's the
distinction there?
Yes. So it's uh the distinction is very popular
in the philosophical field of the end of the
fifth century and the beginning of the fourth century.
So, eogene is like uh uh um appropriating an
idea that has always been uh that, that has
been, I'm sorry, that has been formulated before him,
by Socrates, by uh antisthenes, by Xenophobe. So it's
a very popular idea uh which is the distinction
between the fact of poverty and the feeling of
poverty, meaning uh indigenous point of view, you have
to make a distinction between people who are uh
like uh really poor because they have absolutely nothing
to live and survive and people uh who feel
poor because there are more needs that they have
means, meaning that you can uh extremely wealthy, you
can be one of the wealthiest men of your
city. But if you have uh piled uh lots
of obligations, uh financial ones, personal ones, maybe you
are in difficulty to face all these obligations. So,
uh the, the idea is that you have to,
to see if someone is rich or poor, you
have to look at what he needs on a
regular basis. So he does he have a frugal
life or not? And what are his means? And
even if you have big means, if you have
bigger needs because you are organizing banquets for your
friends all the time because you are financing very
expensive um programs in the city, et cetera. Maybe
you will suffer from a feeling of poverty, even
if not, if on the paper, you're not poor
at all. So that's a kind of very interesting
distinction because it's, it's been um uh it's still
in use in uh contemporary sociology, the distinction between
fact and feeling of poverty. And it came from
uh those from the Socratic school. In fact, Socrates,
Antisthenes xenophobia, genist. So yes, and this is linked
with um this question, in fact, is linked with
the um a kind of revolution in the intellectual
world of the 4th, 5th, 4th century BC, which
is the part of the idea of economy. Um
AT the end of the fifth century and the
beginning of the fourth. So around 400 BC, we
have a series of new words, words uh in
the Greek lexicon were appearing in the language uh
meaning uh econom, uh economical, economical, economia, economia, we
gave that gave birth to our economy, uh econom
uh which mean someone which mean a manager of
his household, uh econo, which means uh someone uh
who has some qualities in management in his private
household. Uh What I'm trying to tell is at
the end of the fifth and beginning of the
first century, there are some new words to describe
a reality which is new to Greek Ice at
the time, which is the uh economic management. Before
that nobody has ever developed a kind of uh
thought about this economic world. And suddenly uh it
appears to Greeks that it is, it is something
you have to understand. And uh of course, as
it's the same time when you have a new
discipline appearing, there is no economist at the time.
So all um the people who are thinking about
this new economy are philos of philosophers. So every
uh uh philosophical school of the time uh has
produced some economic treaties about this question of management.
What it is to uh to be rich, to
be poor, what it, how do you organize your
household or how do you manage your slave? How
do you choose your wife, et cetera, which are
considered as economic questions
a and related to his uh to diogenes econom,
economic ideas. There's also this idea of his criticizing
a system governing the accumulation and distribution of wealth.
Right?
Yes, absolutely. In different ways uh In diogenes, ice
money, coins are a cultural construct. They are useless.
So we shouldn't need coins to, to trade, for
example. So that's maybe the first level. But the
second level is that wealth is not a goal.
You, you, you shouldn't try to get richer because
it's useless. You should do the opposite. You should
try to feel rich by um decreasing your, your
needs. So, in the relationship between means and needs,
uh it says, OK, people are focused on increasing
their means. They shouldn't, they should be focused on
decreasing their needs. And this is cynic uh way
of life. You are supposed to live a very
simple, very frugal, very aic oric uh life. So
yes, that's, that's the idea that's uh wealth on
the field of wealth and patrimony and owning uh
is uh something you have to fight against. This
is useless and this is even more useless in
diogenes eyes because you're not supposed to build a
family on the dynasty. So in Greeks eyes, you
are supposed to build wealth patrimony household because you
want to give it to your heirs. So this
is a family matter, you are supposed to, to
transfer to provide, to increase the family wealth and
to give it to the next generation. And diogenes
says we don't need to make kids and and
we don't need to uh transfer any kind of
wealth. So everything is linked in a way, the
the the need for our family and the need
for the source of wealth are both uh contested
in scenic point of view
and related to the distribution of wealth. Did we
care about economic inequality? For example?
No. Uh YOU couldn't say that really. Uh THERE
is no uh um social conscience in a cynicism
in a way we could say that in a,
in a, in a modern world. Uh FOR, for
diogenes, this is an individual question that is not
really like a social categories uh that we have
to improve the situation as the way to improve
your situation is to live a philosophical life. So
it's not uh um social aid won't help you.
Uh Anyway, social aid in the Greek City is
a very, very tiny uh uh matter for everyone.
But apart from that endogenous uh point of view,
like you said, with the fact of poverty and
the feeling of poverty, that's what you have to
deal with is this uh ability to feel rich
and this is a very individual matter, you have
to face it by yourself. So as long as
you don't, again, for, for cynics, you, you are
not supposed to belong to any kind of category,
including social category.
And of course, he was also a mendicant philosopher,
he practiced mendicancy. And back then, how did uh
Greeks look at that way of living? I mean,
was that also a sort of violation of some
norms in Greek society?
Yeah, you could say that. Yes. Uh It's uh
um for Greek of the first century, a beggar
is a parasite basically. Uh It is considered as
a parasite because the main um uh the main
social value in the relationship is, is what they
call Philia, which is a known philosophical concept. We
uh we often uh translate it by friendship, but
the the closest translation would be will be reciprocity.
Uh So uh what does it mean? It means
that you are in a world where there is
no social security, there is no insurance, meaning that
the level of protection on, on security and safe
social safety you can get is heavily linked with
the number of um reciprocal relationship. You build with
people, with your friends, with your family, with your
neighbors, with uh the citizens of your city. So
uh you build relationship. What does it mean in
everyday life? It means that if you have a
sacrifice, you sacrifice an animal because you have, you
are uh organizing the wedding of your daughter, for
example. Uh THEN if you don't invite your neighbor,
you will come to your neighbor and you will
give your neighbor a piece of the sacrifice because
maybe in two months, in three months, you will
have a problem. You will be on your field
and you will break a tool and you will
need your neighbor to, to borrow uh a tool.
So uh um that's, that's the way Greeks understand
social life. You are, you are giving to people
and they are giving to you when you need
something. So it works in the family. It works
with one. It, it works with neighbors. The thing
is uh um beggars, they don't, they are not
part of that uh like virtual circle. They are
away from that because they never give anything. Basically,
they only ask for arms. So uh they are
considered as a um lost causes if you want.
There is a uh a Greek proverb saying something
like uh uh not even uh um not even
a beggar's parents or his friends. Uh So So,
meaning that you, if you are a beggar, you
are alone, you are by yourself. Uh So they
are the, the, the basic conception of a man
decency is that uh beggars are parasites. And then
cynics come and they change the, the, the pattern.
They say uh that of course, they ask for
something, they ask for arms, but in exchange, they
provide philosophy, they provide advice, they provide wisdom, they
provide clarity of thinking, et cetera. So they are
giving something in return. And that is a Greek
word to say, to ask for S uh E
and there is a Greek word to say to
give something in return at it. Meaning that in
the, in the Greek conception, in the cynic conception,
I mean, uh the fact of begging is not
a parasite attitude. It's a kind of give and
take attitude. So that is what is really new
with uh um uh cynic uh philosophy. It is
um giving birth to the, the idea that a
beggar uh the life of begging can be a
life of philosophy.
And by the way, of course, we tend to
associate diogenes very much with the with these jar.
I mean, many times people talk about it as
being a barrel and not a jar, we can
get into that. But why is the jar so
important as a sort of symbol of his life?
Why do people associate him so much with the
jar?
Um BE first, it's a symbol first. It's a
symbol uh of uh um of frugality of uh
life of uh uh economy. Uh A very uh
uh OIC life, very simple life. So that's first,
that's a symbol. But the thing is in real
life, that's the way it could be for some
people. Some people were living in empty graves, in
cabins, in huts, in tents and in jars. And
we know that from the fifth century during the
Peronne Asian War, we have some uh text mainly
a text from toy leaders, the historian, the main
historian of the Peronne Asian War. Uh AND he's
explaining and he's giving details about the way um
Athenian people had to leave when they took refuge
inside the walls of the city in 431. And
we have information about these temporary shelters, temporary accommodations
and it is empty graves. It is tents and
it is jars. They use jars because those jars
are what Greek call pit oil are very large,
very high ceramic jars. They can be more than
2 m high. We still have some, some of
them thanks to the archaeology of it. And uh
uh they can be very high. They were used
to store food, to store uh uh grain cereals
and different kind of uh different kind of uh
of food. And most of the time they were
put inside the ground like uh uh you have
to dig to put them half of them in
the ground to, to make them stable and then
you could use them in a crisis situation to
live in it. So, and that's what diogenes did
in Athens in the, in the edges of the
Ara, uh, in the metro sanctuary. He had a
jar and he decided to leave to live there.
No, we have no idea how the jar arrived
there, but it must have been a jar from
the sanctuary and then it was empty and uh
someone maybe cleaned it, maybe not. Uh ANYWAY, he,
he used it uh to, to live there for,
for some time. So it's not a tale or
legend. It's a uh it's a normal um uh
crisis uh housing in certain, in certain context. So
when uh when Diogenes in the 300 sixties, 300
fifties did that in Athens, lots of Athenians had
already seen some people living in this kind of
drought. So this is no surprise. Uh FOR them,
this is not a kind of abnormal way of
living. It's not usual on the Agora, but it's
not totally uh unique or crazy. And then uh
the story has uh changed in Roman times when
uh Latin philosophers and Latin writers began to tell
Diogenes story in Latin. And they had to translate
from Phos the Greek work to the draw to
a kind of uh Latin equivalent. And they used
uh do mainly uh which is a way to
say barrel, uh a cask, wooden cask. And uh
but when they did that translation, they knew they
were uh um they knew that the original word
was meaning ceramic jar. They were just adjusting to
their uh l uh But then after that, the
memory of that got lost in the way. And
after, during some centuries, we've been uh describing painting,
showing, telling that diogenes lived in a barrel. So
we have lots of uh modern paintings, for example,
with uh Diogenes in um in a barrel and
lots of books talking about Diogenes barrel, which is
a pure le for, this is a pure legend
because when Diogenes was alive in the first century
BC, there was no wooden barrel on earth. The,
the first uh cask um the first barrels uh
to store wine uh appeared. Uh We have some
archaeological data and we have some text appeared during
the first century BC. So basically 300 years after
the Eugene's life. So he has never lived in
a barrel in Athens. He lived in a jar
and this jar is uh uh is uh at
the same time, a kind of um he is
reflecting the place of the, the role of ceramic
stuff in everyday life. There is a lot of
ceramic uh vessel in uh in uh everyday life
in Athens. At the time, there is a huge
ceramic uh production area in the north of uh
of Athens called Krauss.
Mhm. And of course, as a foreigner and a
mendicant philosopher back then, of course, he had very
low social status. But I guess that a class
of people that probably were even lower in social
status than him were the slaves. And so, because
we've already mentioned, hear that he was a slave
in himself for a while. What ideas did he
have about slaves? I mean, how did they think
about them? Did they think that they were like
other common citizens? They, they were the same as
other people or not?
Yeah. The, the uh uh to diogenes mind it
is status is irrelevant in a way. So you
are as free as you want to be, whatever
is your status. So there is no like a
political claim uh against, against slavery. Um But the
idea is that you um what is interesting uh
diogenes is less slavery than dependence. You are um
you are free if you do not depend, if
you don't depend of any kind of uh uh
specific uh need. So you have to, to build
uh the strongest autonomy, you can the strongest freedom
and this you can do inside a slave life.
So the fact that you are a slave doesn't
mean that you cannot live a philosophical life in
diogenes uh point of view. So uh slavery in
a way is not a very um important matter
in a way that uh cynics use it mainly
as a model as a metaphorical model to dependence.
You are, the point is to try not to
be depend of dependent of anything. Meaning that if
you are a master and if you own many
slaves, but if your full life depends on your
slave, if you are unable to do anything by
yourself, and if you have a level of comfort
that is uh strongly based on the way you
own slave, you are in fact more a slave
than your slaves. So, so in uh in diogenes
point of view, again, it's a question of uh
we would say to the per personal development. Uh
YOU, you, you have to be able to uh
to build uh a kind of space of freedom
in your life. Whatever is your status. Of course,
if you have a free status, it will be
easier, but uh it will come with more obligations
sometimes. So maybe it will be more difficult in
a way. So when you say that uh slaves
are even a harder situation that uh um foreigners,
in fact with uh beggars, we, we could ask
the question because in a way laves there are
some uh they have some reciprocal relationship with the
master with all the slaves. So they can, they
can have kind of uh some protections in a
way that beggars won't get from anyone. So, so
sometimes uh slaved as other better lives than beggars
or may maybe a more protected one even.
Mhm Yeah. Perhaps I was thinking more about the
sort of modern point of view where being a
slave would be worse than being a beggar because
at least the beggar would have more freedom. Yeah.
Yeah. But you're on paper, you're absolutely right on
paper. The, the worst stages is to be a
state. But the thing is in everyday life, some
slaves have uh money, have a comfort, comfortable life
and can be protected. Meaning if they have a
value to their master and if they are molested
by someone, the master will prosecute injustice for them.
So uh uh which that this is something that
nobody will do for a be so, so uh
so um that's a complex situation. That's a complex
situation.
So, getting into other aspects of diogenes philosophy, it
is pleasure, a legitimate desire for diogenes and the
cynics more generally.
Um All the cynics didn't have the same uh
opinion about that. Antinous uh with a kind of
master of Diogenes. Um Antus was refusing pleasure at
least as far as we can understand antinous philosophical
proposal. So, uh which uh Diogenes didn't do uh
part of life. Uh So uh scenic philosophy with
diogenes and after diogenes is not uh um refusal
of pleasure, philosophy. Um THE thing is again, is
the question of autonomy and dependence. Pleasure is a
problem. If you are dependent of a pleasure, you
can drink some wine. But if you need to
drink wine every, every week or at every banquet.
There is a problem. You can have a sexual
life. But, uh, if you are addicted to it,
it's a problem. You can, you have the right
to love food and to enjoy a good piece
of bread and nice olive oil. It's no problem
with that. But again, if you cannot live without
it, then it's a problem. So, pleasure is not
in itself, um, uh, has no moral issue or
ethical issue in itself. The question is uh if
you are dependent of one or other kind of
pleasure
and, and how did they think about other animals?
Did they see? Did they look in any way
at other animals as a possible model for human
conduct? At least to some extent?
Yes. Uh Yeah, the, the the animals are model
to uh to scenic uh meaning that uh they
have an ability uh to uh simplicity, to oar
to uh frugality, which is much bigger than men.
So in the scenic point of view, you have
gods on the top, you have animals in the
middle and you have men in the bottom. So
that's the cynic hierarchy of the uh world in
a way. And then you have um wise uh
men, philosophers that sometimes uh can be higher than
the animals, but lower than the gods like in
between. But uh for normal um animals are supposed
to be a model first because they live a
life of simplicity. They don't have so many needs
uh and they adjust uh their uh needs to
their means. Um So they live a life of,
of frugality and then some specific animals in the
scenic point of view, like dogs will have some
uh uh qualities uh uh that should be inspiring.
Uh DOGS are low. Uh They are honest. Uh
THEY are, again, they live a simple, very simple
life so you can give them a bone and
they will be very happy with that. So, uh
the, the idea is that the animal world and
some of the animals specifically uh can be used
as a model for, for human conduct. Yes.
Mhm. And related some other, let's say norms in
Greek society. Of course, we've already talked a little
bit here about marriage for example. But what worries
views exactly about things like marriage, pity and prostitution.
Um So marriage is a cultural construct in a
scenic point of view. So you are uh you
are not supposed to try to get married. So
we have one exception. Uh uh ONE of diogenes
pupils, Krates who got married with Hipaa. But it
was a very strange marriage was basically unbuilding every
rule of uh marriage. So it's not very classical
uh marriage, you could say. So, uh marriage is
a social convention. Uh PACY is, it's a very
common practice in Athens in the fourth century BC,
meaning that uh uh for me, for most of
men, adult men, I mean, free men citizen or
foreigner, but free men. Uh It was normal to,
um, you had like basically two sexual options on
the table if I could say that, um, women
and boys when I say boys, I mean, uh,
boys, uh which are not adults yet. So let's
say 10 to 20 boys if you want 20
years boys. Um So this was considered as a
kind of too equal uh possibility to, uh, to
live a sexual life. And you, lots of men
were leaving the both possibilities in parallel. Uh So
this is a very common way uh um to,
to do things. Uh But we have no uh
not a single detail about any pistic relationship of
diogenes. The only anecdotes we have around that are
presenting him as a kind of protector of kids.
Uh Not someone who was uh using them, using
them for pleasure or not someone who was using
pacy as a way to educate kids because that's
why that's the way Greeks were describing this social
practice, a way to um get boys to become
uh citizens, adults through a personal, intimate and intellectual
relationship. Uh So, uh to, to no marriage, basically,
no pity and uh with prostitution. Uh You asked,
uh we know that he had a personal relationship
with the Athenian uh prostitute but not uh um
not a relationship involving money. So it was not
as far as we know, it was not a
commercial trade uh relationship. It was a kind of
uh love uh uh normal, intimate personal uh relationship.
So, uh um again, with prostitution uh in diogenes
uh conception, apart from his personal life, the, the
question is the level of dependence. So he was
making fun of people were going on a regular
basis to see prostitutes because in diogene ice and
in scenic Ice, this was a red flag. It
meant that you were, you were dependent of it,
of this kind of pleasure. And this was a
problem in a philosophical point of view. If you
cannot live without it, then you have to uh
to face the philosophical issue. It is.
Mhm And what were his views on athletic competition?
Exercise and health?
Um So, so maybe there are two parts. Uh
THE, the, the, the, the, the exercise uh is
uh good in a cen point of view, you
are supposed to uh exercise your body because your
body is the main tool of your everyday philosophy.
So you are supposed to be uh to try
to be in good shape, to uh to strengthen
your, your, your body, to train it. Uh And
diogenes was known to um even to twist some
athletic exercises like uh uh what you would say,
I am not sure what is the English word
to say that like there was some uh gym,
gymnastic exercises with statue, like statue grabbing, you were
working with statue with positions, statues that were in
the gymnasium. And instead of using it for wrestling
techniques to, to train some wrestling techniques and attitudes,
diogenes was using these statues when they were covered
with snow in winter to grab them and to
uh um train to resist to the cold. So,
uh and that's a good anecdote because it's showing
that at the same time to exercise your body,
to strengthen your body was important, but it was
not to uh uh to prepare to some competition
or to improve in some very specific technical uh
sport. And that's why I was saying that there
are like two parts to the answer. The first
thing is health is important because the body has
to be strong to help the philosophy. But then
sport athletes competition, that's something that has a very
uh strong uh and uh unfavorable opinion because uh
competition again is um a frame to search for
glory. So uh athletes are focused on the search
for glory uh which is a problem in a
phys view. We, we talked about it and the
second is they are uh so focused on that,
that they are only training their body and they
are not um having a kind of uh um
intellectual uh development of education in parallel. So in
diogenes point of view, uh the problem with athletics
is at the same time, the obsession for victory
and the, the fact that you neglect to develop
your mind and not only your, your, your body
So the, the view on uh exercise is positive
but the view on athletics is negative.
And of course, another interesting thing about diogenes is
that he was all about speaking one's mind freely
and sometimes that would entail insulting reprimanding sarcasm. So
te tell us about that.
Um Yeah, that's one of the, um, maybe most
interesting part of the philosophy of uh cynics are
in a way. Um They, they, they consider, they
have a kind of mission you could say. So
they are trying to get more people come to
philosophy, philosophical ideas, philosophical attitude and, and life. So
you have to go to people and to provide
some philosophical experience by talking with them by dialogue,
et cetera. Uh INCLUDING insult, including uh sarcasm. Every
way is good to uh to um to force
people to philosophy. So the, that's, that's really a
kind of philosophy with uh no old bar in
a way that you, you, you, you uh cynic
philosophers consider they have the right to do everything
if it helps philosophy or if it helps someone
to come to philosophy. So they will use every
means to provoke philosophical conversation, philosophical uh situations. The
key principle is uh what the Greek called parea,
meaning, meaning, uh uh freedom of speech, speaking freely,
speaking tersely, uh uh speaking with no um specific
courts of any kind. Uh Because Cortesi is a
social convention on what you have to do is
to force people to understand they are not living
a life of philosophy and to try to convince
them to, to try to live a philosophical life.
So, yes, that is uh uh one of the
main tools of uh cynics when they try to
convince other people to come to philosophy is uh
freedom of speech, Parecia. So uh very, sometimes very
aggressive way to uh to get in contact with
people.
And do you think that his defense of speaking
one's mind and being honest relates in any way
with these hate toward demagogues and populists?
Yes, you, you could say that you could say
that um the thing is uh populist uh in
uh uh political life of uh cities, big cities
or little cities, but mainly big cities like Athens.
Um There are people who are trying to get
some political power. Um And we are ready to
say whatever citizens uh want to hear. So, uh
the main uh tool of a populist is to
lie uh to life, to get uh the power
you want to get to, to be able to
uh decide of some uh of the political lines
of the community. So, uh at the same time,
they are lying, which is uh in a scenic
point of view, uh not an appropriate way of
behaving. And at the same time, they are pursuing
an artificial goal which is power. Uh So they
behave dishonestly on the search for uh something which
is uh in fact useless. So for these two
reasons, uh you, you could say that uh um
to speak one's mind is in contradiction with the
populist uh model. So the scenic way of speaking,
one's mind is in contradiction with the, with the
populist and demagogue model. Yes.
And, and there are certain very curious supposed episodes
in diogenes life, like for example, his supposed encounter
with Alexander, the great that people disseminate a lot,
but we are actually not sure if that really
happened, right?
Uh Yeah, we cannot be sure. The thing is
the, the question is, do we have reason to
believe it happened? That's, that's the main question we
could, we could ask. Yes. Uh And uh yes,
we have reason to believe the met. Uh First
Alexander had a strong interest uh to philosophy. He's
been educated partly by Aristotle and he made several,
he met, sorry, several philosophers through his lives. For
example, Kates when he, when he was in t
uh et cetera. And uh so uh if Alexander
had an opportunity to meet Diogenes, there is no
reason to doubt that they didn't meet. And the
thing is they had some opportunities mainly during the
303 100 in 338 when Diogenes was involved in
the Kona battle in which Alexander was involved too.
Uh And in 336 2 years later, uh Diogenes
was during a part of the year in Athens
during the other part of the year in Corinth.
And Alexander went during that year in those two
cities and even twice in Corinth during that year.
So yes, to answer your question clearly, we cannot
be sure, but we have many good reasons Alexander
would have been interested to meet theogenes. He had
several opportunities to do it. And we have text
describing the uh the encounter, of course, the the
the texts are describing the encounter in a very
legend way. So, so uh behind your question, I
think that's, that's what you mean. Is there, is
there a part of legend in here? And yes,
there, there is, there must be a part of
legend in it. And the legend goes quite far
because the legend tells us that they died the
same day. Uh So they are supposed to have
died the same day. We know exactly when uh
Alexander died during the night of the 10th to
the 11th of June 323. We have no clue
for diogenes. We have some reason to believe he's
dead during the 300 twenties, maybe in 323. This
is possible, but we have no detail and clearly
this detail, the idea that they are, they died
at the exact same day. This is a part
of the legend, Greeks love this kind of uh
synchronic events or alleged synchronic events. So there are
some parts that are completely probable and some parts
that are um likely legends.
But, but when diogenes died, I mean, as, at
least as far as we know, we must have
been in his, uh, like early eighties or something
like that.
Yeah, we have, we don't know, we have different
information about the date of birth. So I wouldn't,
uh, give a precise age but we know he
was around 80 a bit more than, uh, 80.
Yes. Uh, ABSOLUTELY. Uh, IT'S difficult to be more
uh more precise. Yeah, because we don't know when
he died and we don't know when he's born.
So,
yeah. And by the way, when it comes to
his death, how did he die? And in this
particular case, what does it matter? Uh uh THE
the way a philosopher dies does it matter and
why?
Yes. So, so, so for the first part of
your question, we have several um versions of his
death with different, different dates and different context. So
uh for the way he died, we have at
least four different version. One saying that he died
of eating a raw octopus uh trying to demonstrate
that cooking was useless. Um Why one that he
died of an infection after being bitten by dogs
with which he was disputing a piece of octopus.
Uh One telling us that he died of self
suffocation uh on the car in Khan, on the
heel of the car in Khan with his own
cloak. Um One telling us that he died of
fever So of course, he cannot um he, he
cannot have been uh killed by these four reasons.
So most of them are wrong, maybe all of
them, which is likely uh he might have just
died of age. He was a very old man.
And uh so we have, we have no clue.
But I think is why do we have so
many legends? Because exactly that's the question you ask
is, is there a physical way of dying? And
this is, these legends are a way to express
the idea that there is a philosophical way of
uh of dying in ancient times. The death of
a philosopher is supposed to be uh the the
last uh demonstration of his philosophy. So uh we
have lots of anecdotes, biographical anecdotes about philosopher showing
that they were um uh either very close to
their philosophy when they die when they died or
on the contrary, extremely far from their philosophy are
in contradiction with their philosophy when they, when they
died. So there is a uh very uh there's
a huge interest in the scientific uh ancient world
about the death of uh philosophers because again, this
is this idea that philosophy uh can be demonstrated
through your actions and your death is in a
way the last even it's the last even of
your life. Did you leave it in a philosophical
way or did you not? And diogenes is not
an exception. The legends around his life are in
a way exploring the idea of, did he, did
he live a scenic death or not?
Yeah. The, there's also that, uh tale II, I
would call it a tale because I am not
100% sure if it's true or not, but about
epicurus where I mean, because of the way he
fought about that and now we shouldn't fear death
that he apparently, he died with a very severe
illness and he apparently was suffering a lot. But
because of his idea of death, he should have
died peacefully. Right. Yeah, exactly. That's another example, I
guess. Yeah. Yeah, you have, in fact, uh lots
of examples that have been gathered by a French
researcher some years ago in an article Lucien Jaron,
which it's an article in French, which is uh
the southern, the southern way of death of dying
of ancient philosophers. So, yes, you're right there, there
are lots of examples and some of them are
dying exactly the way you are. They are expected
to die and others are like uh in full
contradiction. So it's, it's a, it's a, it's a
way, it's a funny part of the philosophical history
of philosophy, if I could say
by the way, in, in what ways did die
is relate philosophically intellectually, of course, to some of
the other very prominent Greek philosophers like Socrates and
Plato, they, they have something to say about their
philosophy or the, their way of doing philosophy or
something like that.
Yeah. Uh WI with uh um Diogenes as far
as we know, as a kind of uh um
very critic uh opinion about Socrates and extremely critic
uh opinion about Plato. Uh THE, the that uh
he was considering Plato that a kind of um
ne negation of uh of the principle of uh
philosophy in action. The, the main critic Diogenes was
uh uh doing at uh uh Plato and Plato's
philosophy. That was that he was not living a
life of philosophy. It was just like producing philosophical
ideas, but you couldn't see. And then in his
uh everyday uh life, so he wasn't, he was
useless in, in Diogenes's point of view, plateau was
uh uh was useless. And he says that he
said something like uh of what's used for us.
He is a man who's been philosophy for uh
so long and has yet not upset uh anyone.
So he was considering him as a kind of
a lost cause someone was producing very high level
philosophical ideas, but that we are not grounded. So
that was the main critic. And about, you know,
the idea of the human being, the way a
plateau defined what is a human being. So, meaning
a biped uh with no leaves um with no
feathers, sorry with no feathers. Um And then uh
uh Theogenes says the legend uh took a rooster
plucked, the, the rooster came to the um to
uh Plato's gymnasium and said this is Plato's human
being uh to, to, to make fun to the,
this kind of philosophical corpus. So, uh Diogenes was
i, in that way, he was positioning himself against
uh plateau's school that he considered as a kind
of very theoretical philosophy and not a philosophy in
action. Mhm.
And uh do we know if Biogen wrote a
lot? Uh I mean, did he write at all?
Uh AS far as we know he did, he
did uh essays uh Economic Treaties Tragedies too. We
have two long lists of his opera. Uh They
are not exactly identical. There are reasons for that
but maybe I won't go so far in the
conversation. But, but uh uh we have no reason
to doubt that he wrote. He wrote meaning that
he must have had some kind of material support,
material help. Uh BECAUSE you need some scrolls, you
need, you need to have some material to write
in ancient times like today, I could say. Uh
BUT yes, he, he wrote, he used writing to
develop his ideas including tragedies again, Seattle. Uh But
the thing is we, we lost everything basically apart
from a, a big fragment of his uh um
uh Political Philosophy Treaty uh polit that we, we,
we, we, we, which is, which has been saved
by Philo Dema of Garra and quoted. But apart
from that, we lost uh most of his text.
So we know his philosophy from uh his uh
Apotex. And for his um sayings, so the, the,
the big part of his philosophy, we, we grasp
it, we get uh it's true uh anecdotes, uh
meetings, encounters and the dialogues he had with uh
some people. So some of these sayings are, must
have been close to the truth, other are very
uh rebuilt by time and uh diff the different
philosophical schools that use them uh to defend cynicism
or to attack cynicism. So sometimes it's a bit
difficult to see through this uh uh very long
and complex transmission process to get to go back
to the like original diogenes
and which prominent philosophers uh mentioned having been influenced
by diogenes. And I'm not just asking about the
Greek and Roman philosophers, but basically across history.
Um And that's, that's, I'm not sure I am
able to fully answer to the, to the question.
But I would, to, to my knowledge, the, the
um the philosopher who has been the, maybe the
most influenced by uh diogenes. He will be Emil
Cioran, the Romanian uh philosopher
from the 19th century.
Uh A bit uh a bit after that. He,
he died. Uh I don't remember exactly when he
died. I don't know if he died end of
the 20th or beginning of the 21st. I'm sorry,
Emil C
Yeah. Yeah, I know, I know who you're talking
about. I, I just thought that he was born
in the 19th century but perhaps I'm
wrong, maybe no, I wouldn't say that. I don't
think so. I think he's born in the beginning
of the twenties. But you, you maybe, you know,
better. The so, so, so which was a Romanian
philosopher? But he lived in, not in exile. But
yes, he lived in gold books in Romanian. Then
it changed uh to uh to French on the
road the rest of his life. Uh IN um
in French, he lived a very simple uh life
uh basically with no uh family, a very poor
life. He didn't work. Uh He wrote mainly uh
a aorist sayings. So even the way he was
communicating philosophy uh as some has something in common
with the way we know uh diogenes uh philosophy.
It was very critical with basically uh everything in
the social uh about social customs, social conventions. So,
um a very uh uh brutal uh way of
looking at uh humans and their behavior and society.
So, um I would say maybe uh the, the,
the, the, the, the biggest he uh of the
20th century will be em. Yes.
Mhm. And what about the influence that diogenes might
have had on stoicism? The, did, did they have
an influence there?
Yes. Yes. Uh The first influence is uh genealogy.
Uh The, you know, Socrates are uh antisthenes as
a pupil, antitheism, a diogenes as a pupil uh
di direct or indirect pupil. We, we are not
sure that depending diogenes arrived in Athens before the
death of antisthenes in 366 or after. We're not
sure. Diogenes at Ks as a pupil and CS
as Z and Zeno is the founder of the
stoic school of South. Um So there is a
genealogical link. That's the first thing. The second thing
is there is an ideological link. Yes. Uh Stoics
in a way are like uh civilized cynics. If
you could say uh Cynics, you can be in
company with without being insulted. Um So the the
level of the of provocation transgression uh exhortation to
is much uh lower. But there, there are some
common points. It's a, it's a stoic stoicism is
an ethic philosophy as cynicism uh virtue. The search
for virtue is key in uh stoicism. And uh
there is this idea that you, you cannot be
controlled by your feelings. Uh uh The cynics will
say that you cannot be controlled by your needs.
Stoics will say that you cannot be controlled by
your feelings, meaning you cannot be controlled by your,
by your pain or by your pleasure, which is
a common point with uh uh Cynics. Uh There
is another strong common point is it is a
philosophy in action. Stoics uh consider that the way
you behave is key in a philosophical point of
view. Again, it's not a theoretical philosophy. There is
a theoretical um corpus which is uh uh explaining
uh analyzing the, the idea of virtue, the relationship
to Phoenix, et cetera. But what is most important
is the way you uh you behave. And maybe
there is another element which is the relationship with
nature. For Stoics to understand the rules of nature
is key to uh choose your philosophical way of
life. You need to stay in contact with the
rules of uh nature. So, yes, there are, there
are lots of lots in common. But again, Stoics
must have been much easier to um comp sti
company must have been much easier and nicer than
Phoenix one,
right? And, and by the way, actually, I've asked
you about stoicism specifically because we've seen in recent
years uh resurgence of spices in popular culture actually.
But uh do you look at these recent resurgence
uh as and as having anything to do with
the original sto
Yeah, I don't know if it's more stoicism or
more cynicism, the, the this uh the, the development
of the search of frugality, achy, um self sufficiency.
Um I, I think that some people will, will,
will uh claim to be influenced by the model.
Some will claim to be influenced by the stoic
uh model. I, I have never made a kind
of a full survey of the phenomenon. You're right.
I think it's an increasing trend movement across the
world of people who are trying to rethink our
relationship to progress. And cynics and Stoics are of
can be of great help to uh to rethink
the relationship to, to progress the idea that we
have to accumulate more and more to, to, to
produce uh more and more. Um SOME people are
trying to live a kind of decreasing uh life
in that uh perspective. And, and diogenes is kind
of uh the ultimate model of life in that
uh uh perspective. So, yes, there is a kind
of uh um uh increasing popularity of this uh
ancient philosophic uh movement, ancient philosophies in actions uh
that are more popular than they've been uh doing.
I would say a century ago, the popularity of
this movement was not the same in the, in
the population, not in the academic world, but in
the uh normal world, I would
say. So, one last question, then how do you
look basically at the legacy of diogenes? I mean,
how is he viewed today by philosophers in general
and in popular culture?
Um I think there is still some time um
uh is still forgotten, sometimes it was forgotten sometime
in the ancient uh uh time in antiquity. Uh
Some histories of philosophy, I mean, in the ancient
times, uh uh forgot to uh to study uh
uh cynicism and it still happens sometimes you have
some very large book about ancient philosophy. We don't
uh even credit anything to uh cynicism. So uh
that is a kind of very old uh tendency
but uh things are, things are changing. Uh I
think in that, in that matter. So that is
a kind of uh rehabilitation of the interest of
uh cynicism because of his genealogy with the Socratic
philosophy and the stoic uh philosophy that is a
kind of rehabilitation. Uh AND the, the fact that
we are facing this very modern question of uh
and the way the world is uh going now
and the economics, the industrial uh uh issues we
are, all of us are, are, are facing. Uh
IT should, it should give to uh cynicism a
kind of new uh uh new light on.
Mhm Great. So uh the book is again the
Dangerous Life and ideas of diogenes, the cynic. I'm
leaving a link to it in the description of
this interview. And uh J Manuel, just before we
go apart from the book, would you like to
tell people where they can find you on the
internet? Uh
What can you mean if I have some kind
of
internet? Yeah, like uh university page website, social media.
I,
I have no social media page of any kind.
I don't have any Facebook page, Instagram page, Twitter
page uh or youtube channel. Uh I just have
a professional page uh where my uh work is
uh uh referred. Uh So uh when I release
a new uh a new study, a new book,
uh you, you can uh find it uh there.
Uh So that, that's it. Basically, I'm afraid I'm
not a, a very electronic uh
person. Uh And do you have, for example, fuel
uh uh few people profile or Research Gate or
something like that.
Um I, I'm sorry, I did not understand your
question
because. Ok. Ok. So, uh thank you so much
again for coming on the show. It's been a
real pleasure to talk
to you the same. Thank you very much.
Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview. Until
the end. If you liked it, please share it.
Leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by N Lights learning
and development. Then differently check the website at N
lights.com and also please consider supporting the show on
Patreon or paypal. I would also like to give
a huge thank you to my main patrons and
paypal supporters, Perera Larson, Jerry Muller and Frederick Suno
Bernard Seche O of Alex Adam, Castle Matthew Whitting
B are no wolf, Tim Ho Erica LJ Conners,
Philip Forrest Connelly. Then the Met Robert Wine in
NAI Z Mar Nevs calling in Hobel Governor Mikel
Stormer Samuel Andre Francis for Agns Ferger Ken Hall,
her ma J and Lain Jung Y and the
Samuel K Hes Mark Smith J Tom Hummel s
friends, David Sloan Wilson Yaar, Roman Roach Diego, Jan
Punter, Romani Charlotte, Bli Nicole Barba, Adam Hunt, Pavlo
Stassi na Me, Gary G Almansa Zal Ari and
YPJ Barboza Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Broder Douglas
Fry Franka, La Gilon Cortez or Solis Scott Zachary
ftdw Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgio, Luke Loi.
Georgio Theophano, Chris Williams and Peter Wo David Williams
Di A Costa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore Larry Dey Junior, Old
Ebon, Starry Michael Bailey. Then Spur by Robert Grassy
Zorn. Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radick, Mark Temple,
Thomas Dvor Luke Neeson, Chris Tory Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin
Gilbert Jessica. No week in the B brand Nicholas
Carlson Ismael Bensley Man, George Katis, Valentine Steinman Perros,
Kate Van Goler, Alexander Abert Liam Dan Biar Masoud
Ali Mohammadi Perpendicular J Ner Urla. Good enough, Gregory
Hastings David Pins of Shan Nelson, Mike Levin and
Jos Net. A special thanks to my producers is
our web, Jim Frank Luca Toni, Tom Ween, Bernard
N Cortes Dixon Bendik Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine and
Patrick Tobin John Carl Negro, Nick Ortiz and Nick
Golden. And to my executive producers Matthew Lavender, Si
Adrian Bogdan Knits and Rosie. Thank you for all.